-Welcome to the show!
-Ah, it's good to be here.
Thank you, Seth.
Good to see you again.
-It is a delight to see you,
as always.
Very crowded Democratic field.
I want to ask about this
real quick.
-Yeah.
-Some people getting in late
Maybe Michael Bloomberg,
Deval Patrick.
-Mm.
-Now's your chance.
[ Laughter ]
-Looks like fun.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-I'm a recovering politician
-Yeah, you're --
You're fully --
-Used the line before,
but the longer I go
without a relapse,
the less likely one becomes.
-Oh, that's good.
Well, we wish you the best
of luck in your recovery.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I do want to talk
about the environment,
obviously, having you here
but I do, with impeachment -
You know,
you were in the White Hous
the last time there was
impeachment going on.
What is your take?
-It's so fun
to remember those days.
-I know, right?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-Just good old times.
The '90s, right?
Remember the '90s?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know, I think
one thing that people keep
drawing a distinction
as far as that time
and the present is,
you guys did try to go
about your business
of running the country.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that one
of the major differences?
Are there others you see?
-[ Laughs ] Well...
[ Laughter ]
I'm so tempted to get into thi
full bore.
but I'm not going to do it
-Yeah.
-It would not go well.
Well, I mean --
Look, I honestly believe,
[chuckles] Seth,
that all joking aside,
this is the most dangerous tim
for the United States of America
I've ever seen in my lifetime,
and there is just
a radical all-out assault
from Donald Trump
on the values of America,
the norms of America,
the rule of law in America
So, I'm impressed with the way
the House Intelligence Committee
is going about these hearings,
and I think it's having
an impact.
People are seeing these
incredibly honest,
hard working women and men
who have been
serving our country
in the Foreign Service
and in other ways,
and I think they're, you know --
I think they're making
a big impression,
and Trump is going after the
even as they're up there,
still serving the country,
telling the truth.
-You -- It might--
-I'm sorry there's not
many laughs in that.
-No, I...
I mean, it must have felt --
Obviously, in --
when you were in office,
it must have felt like
a very partisan time then.
-Mm.
-With that said,
are you just blown away
by where we're at now
as far as the divide
in the country
versus a time that must have
felt fraught in the moment
but now seems fairly quain
compared to what
we're going through now?
-Yeah, I think that
the partisanship
is more extreme now.
There have, of course, bee
periods in our country's history
where it was way more extrem
than it is now.
We want to forget --
Anyway, but, yes,
it's very tribal now
in the sense that --
But I don't want
to answer your question
in a way that implies
that it's sort of equal
on both sides.
-Mm-hmm.
-There's some of that.
Now, my Republican friends
will not--
Well, some of them
agree with me,
that there is a group
in the Republican Party
that has made a decision
to just follow Donald Trum
no matter what he says,
no matter what he does.
If he attacks a Gold Star
mother and father,
that's fine with them
or they'll not say anythin
about it not being fine,
and I think
that's something new.
I think it's unhealthy.